Nikki Bella and Artem jimin's EV are
officially official the pair released
this video to announce they dig in the
next step in their relationship the main
reason why we did this dance
it's kind of what to know what I mean I
guess to like like what you know don't
do it up I guess that we're like we're
boyfriend and girlfriend
it's very dear to both of our hearts and
it's kind of just it's so emotional it's
crazy that's the bear talking on Nikki
and Brie's podcast
the Bellas podcast where Nikki reveals
why she chose Rita Ora's let me love you
as the song this song really hit me hard
because I just felt like okay I'm
falling for this guy really fast but I
want not that I want to avoid it but I
just kept trying to push shard him away
because I would just wasn't ready for
anything
[Music]
Nikki and Artem first met on Dancing
with the Stars in 2017 I loved meeting
Artem and getting to know him and
spending time with him at the time Nikki
was with John Cena they went through a
very public breakup last year I just
can't imagine my life without you John I
just can't imagine not getting married
and spending the rest of our lives to
get there after that Nikki and Artem
became inseparable and he even appeared
on her a reality show I feel like the
first time ever I'm focusing on me it's
crazy I never in my life would have
thought that like I would have had a lot
in common with the Russian Nikki and
Artem made their red carpet debut as a
couple earlier this month at the Kids
Choice Sports Awards I feel like a I'm
at that age where I'm discovering who I
really am and what do I want out of life
and just like independence and I'm
enjoying I'm mocking allies it's scary
and you have these moments of like what
am i doing and you have fear but I just
I kind of am liking the challenge and
that beer because it's just for soon
about of my comfort zone it's kind of
like dancing
[Music]
[Applause]